i've seen a lot of comments on videos in
the past couple months or on twitter
some of which i can agree with but
they're all sort of looking at phones
coming out these days and saying they're
mostly pretty similar they're all big
screens on rectangular bodies with big
batteries and big cameras and there's
only so much you can do with a rectangle
i also kind of said it but maybe a
little bit differently but in a previous
video i said like we don't even really
measure smartphones by how good they are
anymore or what's so good about them we
measure them by what's wrong with them
and how many flaws they have and if
there's enough flaws to make a phone
like a deal breaker
oh
is
yep see this
this is a classic the droid came out in
2009 and that was the same year that we
had the iphone 3gs so this phone was
aimed directly at that iphone and all
the shots fired in that commercial all
the rips in that ad were shot at the
iphone 3gs and you don't even really see
an entire commercial for a phone
dedicated to comparing yourself to
another phone like that doesn't even
really happen anymore but i'm so glad we
got it because that sort of a diss track
from motorola was pretty good to
highlight a lot of the differences in
style
okay yeah so the iphone had a software
keyboard and the droid
had a physical keyboard that it was
pretty proud of
the iphone was slightly infamous at this
time for not doing multitasking well
and the android phones didn't even
really do it that much better but you
did have sort of a little carousel for
your most recently used apps and you
could sort of switch between them within
ram before they closed so in that way it
was a little better and you could have
that as part of your ad
the iphone 3gs had a three megapixel
camera on the back the droid has a five
megapixel camera and if there was ever a
time that you could convince someone
that higher megapixels and a camera
automatically makes it better it's 2009
this was a big one remember when you
couldn't change your wallpaper on your
iphone this was around that time so you
can kind of see where they're coming
from and this is still an argument used
today people will continue to say that
android phones have way more
customization to the way they look and
the way they operate than on android and
this was super true when it was just ios
3.
this is another android thing uh iphones
still don't run widgets
boy has that changed uh the play store
was a big deal for android at this time
and also the app store was not nearly as
much of a monstrosity as it is for ios
today
so i guess in that category the iphone
wins the most improved award
so the iphone 3gs didn't have a flash on
the back fun fact bet you didn't
remember that also uh
the droid does
so again this phone had a removable back
which would allow you to add micro sd
storage and swap out the battery which
is again two things that the iphone has
not done since and probably will never
do so that's something that's also been
different in style so i think what made
the droid stand out was it was just a
much bigger phone so bigger display had
this keyboard and then the software this
android experience being very different
from ios 3. also this isn't just any
droid this is my droid this is the first
thing i ever reviewed this is should i
link it i'll sure i'll link it i'll
embarrass myself this is the first
review i ever made was of this phone and
i used it every day for like two plus
years and that's a long time for me and
i still i'm not gonna lie and say i
could still use this phone today but
there are a lot of things that still
stand out about it that are good that
are quality things that you look for in
phones right now so it was just kind of
fun to look back at a device that made a
big difference in the way phones are
talked about and the way phones are
viewed today i kind of want to pick up
some other look at some other classic
phones like i would say this is a
classic i would say the first iphone is
a classic i would say the t-mobile g1 i
would like to look at as a classic and
maybe some others around this time too
but my question to you is and this is
kind of an interesting one what do you
think is the oldest phone that you could
still use today like i know people we're
mostly using phones from like the last
three or four years i'm using phones
from this year you might be using the
phone you bought last year or 2015 or 14
but i think i think i could use
this which is the galaxy nexus back from
when it first came out in the verizon
days i think i could use this pretty
confidently as my daily phone right now
i think let me know what you guys think
thanks for watching and i'll talk to you
guys in the next one
peace
i just don't make them like that anymore